OUR ECONOMIC STRATEGY.
AND WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED.
>> BUT WE BEGIN TODAY WITH THE
OTHER MAJOR STORY UNFOLDING
RIGHT NOW AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
IN JUST A FEW MINUTES, PRESIDENT
BIDEN WILL SIGN THAT LEGISLATION
GUARANTEEING THAT STATES HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE SAME-SEX AND
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGES AFTER THE
LAW PASSED CONGRESS WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO CNN'S
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
PHIL MATTINGLY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WALK US THROUGH THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE BILL SIGNING?
>> THERE'S THE POLICY
SIGNIFICANCE AND THE SYMBOLISM
WHICH IS ENORMOUS.
ON THE POLICY SIDE EVEN IN THE
WAKE OF THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION THAT CLEARED THE WAY
FOR SAME-SEX LARGE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THIS WILL SERVE AS A
BACK STOP OF SORTS IT COMPELS
EVERY STATE TO ALLOW GAY
MARRIAGE IF DONE IN ANOTHER
STATE EVEN PERHAPS AT A MOMENT
IT COMES WHEN CERTAIN LAWS ARE
SHIFTED.
AND THAT STATE MAY TRY AND BAN
GAY MARRIAGE.
THAT'S ONE PART OF IT.
THE OTHER IS, IT REPEALS THE
DEFENSIVE MARRIAGE ACT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
FOCUSED ON MUCH.
IT'S TECHNICALLY ON THE BOOKS IN
THE WAKE OF THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION.
THAT DIRECTS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO RECOGNIZE ANY
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE FROM HERE
GOING FORWARD.
THE SYMBOLISM IS ENORMOUS.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON THE SOUTH
LAWN.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE MARKING THIS
MOMENT, PARTICULARLY IN THE WAKE
OF SOME OF THE SUPREME COURT
DECISIONS THAT RAISED QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE DECISION
BACK IN 2015.
THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE ACCORDING
TO SOME OFFICIALS THEY BELIEVE
THERE'S A REASSURANCE HERE THAT
SIMPLY DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE
TODAY.
>> AND PHIL, TODAY'S SIGNING
COMES TEN YEARS AFTER BIDEN'S
FAMOUS TV MOMENT WHEN HE CAME
OUT IN SUPPORT OF SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE BACK 2012, AHEAD OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> AND YEAH, AND THE CAMPAIGN,
YOU'D REMEMBER BETTER THAN
ANYBODY WAS NONE TOO PLEASED BY
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S DECISION TO
DO JUST THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT THAT
MOMENT THAT UNDERSCORES JUST HOW
FAR THE COUNTRY HAS COME IN A
DECADE.
IT SEEMS BIZARRE THAT THIS
WASN'T THE GENERAL POSITION,
POLITICALLY, PARTICULARLY FOR A
DEMOCRATIC VICE PRESIDENT AT THE
TIME.
LISTEN TO WHAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT SAID.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I AM ABSOLUTELY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE FACT THAT MEN MARRYING
MEN, WOMEN MARRYING WOMEN, AND
HETEROSEXUAL MEN MARRYING, ALL
ARE ENTITLED TO SAME CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTIES AND,
QUITE FRANKLY, I DON'T SEE MUCH
OF A DISTINCTION BEYOND THAT.
>> Reporter: JAKE, THAT IS A
MOMENT THAT WILL BE MEMORIALIZED
IN A CARD GIVEN TO EVERYBODY IN
ATTENDANCE.
>> LET'S LISTEN TO HIM NOW PHIL
MATTINGLY, THANKS SO MUCH.
>> A STEP TOWARDS EQUALITY,
TOWARD LIBERTY AND JUSTICE, NOT
JUST FOR SOME.
BUT FOR EDGE.
FOR EVERYONE.
DECENCY, AND LOVE, RECOGNIZED
AND HONORED AND PROTECTED.
TODAY I SIGNED THE RESPECT FOR
MARRIAGE ACT INTO LAW.
DECIDING WHETHER TO MARRY, WHO
TO MARRY, IS ONE OF THE MOST
PROFOUND DECISIONS A PERSON CAN
MAKE.
AS I'VE SAID BEFORE AND SOME OF
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, ON A CERTAIN
TV SHOW TEN YEARS AGO.
I GOT IN TROUBLE.
MARRIAGE, I MEAN THIS WITH ALL
MY HEART, MARRIAGE IS A SIMPLE
PROPOSITION.
WHO DO YOU LOVE?
AND WILL YOU BE LOYAL TO THAT
PERSON YOU LOVE?
IT'S NOT MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT.
AND THE LAW RECOGNIZED THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS FOR
THEMSELVES WITHOUT THE
GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE.
IT ALSO SECURES THE FEDERAL
RIGHTS, PROTECTIONS THAT COME
WITH MARRIAGE.
LIKE WHEN YOUR LOVED ONE GETS
SICK.
AND YOU LEGALLY RECOGNIZED AS
THE NEXT OF KIN, FOR MOST OF OUR
NATION'S HISTORY, WE DENY
INTERRACIAL COUPLES AND SAME-SEX
COUPLES FROM THESE PROTECTIONS.
WE FAILED.
WE FAILED TO TREAT THEM WITH AN
EQUAL DIGNITY.
AND RESPECT.
AND NOW, THE LAW REQUIRES
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE AND
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE MUST BE
RECOGNIZED AS LEGAL IN EVERY
STATE IN THE NATION.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY, FOR BEING PART
OF THIS IMPORTANT MOVEMENT.
JILL, CAMILLA, DOUG, MY CAPTAIN
MEMBERS INCLUDING PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
A SPECIAL THANKS TO OUR
PERFORMERS, JOE, SAM AND CINDY
IN THE GAY MAN'S MARRIAGE CHOIR.
AND MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TODAY,
THE SENATE, THE BIPARTISAN VOTE
SIMPLY WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT THE LEADERSHIP AND
PERSISTENCE OF A REAL HERO,
SENATOR TAMMY BOWLEN.
AND THANK YOU SUSAN COLLINS WHO
DOES NOT REST UNTIL THIS BILL
GOT DONE.
AND LEADERS SCHUMER, SENATORS
PORTLAND, TILLIS, FINESTEIN,
BOOKER.
AND THE HOUSE, AS MUCH WOULDN'T
HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT NANCY
PELOSI, THE SPEAKER.
FOLLOWING THE DIGNITY OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY HAS ALWAYS BEEN
HER NORTH STAR, FROM HER FIRST
SPEECH ON HOUSE FLOOR PLEDGING
TO END AIDS AND SIGNING THE BILL
TODAY, ALL OF THAT TIME SPAN.
MADAM SPEAKER, ON BEHALF OF ALL
AMERICANS, THANK YOU FOR THIS
AND SO MUCH MORE FOR YOUR
DECADES OF SERVICE.
WE ALSO, A SPECIAL THANKS TO
REPRESENTATIVES LIKE JERRY
NADLER WHO FIRST INTRODUCED THE
RESPECT FOR MARRIAGE ACT A
DECADE AGO.
DAVID CICILLINE, AND SHARICE
DAVIDS LEADERS OF THE MINORITY
CAUCUS.
SO MANY MORE WHO DID WHAT WAS
RIGHT.
STANDING BEHIND ME ARE DOZENS OF
PLAINTIFFS.
UP THERE.
DON'T JUMP.
DOZENS OF PLAINTIFFS WHO FOUGHT
FOR MARRIAGE EQUALITY THROUGH
THE YEARS, AS WELL AS FAMILIES
WHOSE EXISTENCE WOULD NOT BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE BONDS OF
LOVE THAT THIS WALL HONORS AND
PROTECTS.
LOOK, WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE THEIR COURAGE AND
EVERYONE WHO MADE THE DAY
POSSIBLE.
COURAGE THAT LED TO PROGRESS
WE'VE SEEN OVER TH